so first i want to start with saying
how great of a job you did with this
movie um i
have nothing but positive things to say
uh congrats
just congrats thank you thank you um but
i have to just jump backwards for a
second and say that watchman was the
best thing of that year
and i also just want to say real quick
how impressed i was
with your work with damon on that
series because it's effing awesome okay
now now that i've done complimenting
you and i normally don't do this but i i
just really have to
um uh i am curious if you could talk a
little bit about um
uh if you maybe reached out because it's
your first time doing a feature like
this
did you reach out to any like director
friends for any sort of advice
prior to filming or were you sort of
like taking notes this whole time like i
got this
um i'm always taking notes along the way
um i'm always reaching out to
my director friends always
even with any of the tv work that i've
done um
i've i've been lucky enough to have
established
really great rapport with directors that
i've worked with
and ones that i want to work with that
have been
very supportive and very open
[Music]
to just share their experiences because
so often you can learn
about what not to do
um from someone else sharing
uh what didn't work uh for them
um so yeah yeah definitely i'm
always reaching out to to my
director peers the film takes place
in 64 but it's as relevant today
as it was back then and this is sort of
a more serious question um but i am
curious do you do you feel like
in the last year with everything that's
happened with the black lives movement
and with
what like what feels like god willing
like a turning point
do you feel like change is on the
horizon like real change or do you feel
like it's still
going to be a struggle for decades to
come
i think that is still going to be a
struggle but i do
feel like we are going to it's
it's interesting because when you just
talk about history you know that you
know when you
in 64 there were these powder keg
moments that were happening in 63
in 64 62 that you know
that were um uh really
um uh that that made
these conversations as raw as they were
because they just happened so um you can
probably cite
many moments of that like that in
history
uh in our american history that uh
are surrounded around race um
and marginalization uh so i
i truly
feel like especially with the events
that just took place
uh this uh past week while
they were horrific uh while they were
saddening um they weren't really
surprising
to me um but i do feel like
some people still are gonna always
we're gonna need to continue telling
these stories we're gonna need to
continue
to report on these
moments that are happening in the world
because that's the only way
that um true change is going to happen
and i think one of the differences today
uh
that um didn't um
exist in 64 is that um
we there are more people huh in the
country
first of all but um we
are
not as scared to be vocal about
um about the evidence
that history has shown us and
um so i feel like it's going to be still
a struggle
but i i i feel like i will see
some transformation in my lifetime
i really want i'm obviously i really
want that to happen
um i know that as more and more people
see this film
um you are going to be offered many
other films to direct
uh because your work on this is
tremendous can you sort of talk about
what you maybe are looking to do in the
future
do you want to tackle more socially
relevant films
or are you actually looking to maybe do
a romantic comedy
i think a little bit of both you know
definitely um you know again like i said
uh you know when i was speaking about uh
because i just want to make clear when i
said
that um you know people are not as
scared
to be vocal now i i really mean
that and you know we you hear us talk
about
uh white people in the struggle as
allies
i feel like um a lot of white people
have not
felt uh comfortable enough
to um uh be vocal
about how they feel you know and as as
well as black people have in the past
so bringing that to your next question
um
because of that i
feel like seeing me
be able to direct a
comedy starring a white cast
is an example of seeing that
um uh change actively happening
and uh that's gonna happen with um
uh people
that are not uh that that that are that
have stories that are not
black stories if you will feeling uh
confident enough to say i want regina to
direct it you know
that that uh uh i i think we're in a
moving into a space
where more of that is happening you know
you're seeing that like with d
reese and her last film and
ava's uh film wrinkle in time and you
know you're
we're starting to see more of that
maybe small but it is happening and
um yeah i want to do it all
i want to tell good stories if i want i
want to make you laugh
i want to make you cry i want to make
you pissed i want you to feel all the
emotions
um listen i already got to go i'm just
going to say again um
i i thought you did such a tremendous
job with this and i really wish you
nothing but the best
ah received thank you so much and
good luck good luck in everything and
have fun walking the dog yeah